bitcoin is up more than 25 over the last
month or so and it looks like the bulls
are in control once again bitcoin is
positive year to date and is
outperforming the stock market and many
other assets in 2022 but the big story
right now is that the bears look
exhausted they just don't have any more
bitcoin to sell into the market if we go
ahead and we take a look at bitcoin it's
just been grinding higher and higher and
higher over the last couple of weeks if
we look to somebody like kyle davies
over at three arrows capital he's got a
great point where he says that there are
no more sellers left after several waves
of bad news there's been leveraged
wipeouts the macro concerns the ukraine
war and much more so it's natural for
bitcoin to have a strong bid here he
then went on to state that funds and
other market participants are sitting on
big cash allocations and as bitcoin
grinds up he expects many others to
chase the market higher of course this
is all happening as somebody like do
quan from tara has already stated that
they're gonna go into the market they're
gonna buy three billion dollars worth of
bitcoin michael saylor is taking out
loans against his bitcoin collateral to
buy more bitcoin in the hundreds of
millions of dollars so then if we go
ahead and we take a look at the exchange
balance how much bitcoin's actually
sitting on these exchanges you can see
that as the price has gone up the
balance on crypto exchanges of bitcoin
has been dropping that gold line
continues to drive deeper and deeper
it's now at about a three and a half
year low if bitcoin's not on the
exchanges it can't be sold and
ultimately this is a sign that the
market is becoming more illiquid when
you have an illiquid market and you have
more demand coming in the sellers have
nowhere to go they simply just become
holders then if we go ahead and we take
a look td ameritrade has a market
strategist which had a great point he
stated that as the market gets a little
bit more differentiated in terms of the
various names or coins that are in there
you start to see them move in a little
bit more of an individual basis as
investors learn how to parse all the
different components the crypto space
will do the same as people become more
familiar with it and there will be a lot
more selective around which individual
coins they have ultimately that is what
we're seeing the market's maturing
people are becoming more educated about
what is bitcoin and how exactly should
it fit into their portfolio the market
is highly illiquid there's a persistent
buyer eating up tons and tons of the
remaining supply and the sellers they're
just exhausted they don't want to sell
anymore they realize that it's likely
bitcoin's going to go higher here and
all that cash that people have been
raising by selling assets over the last
few months it's gonna pour right back
into the hardest soundest money in the
world
this next couple of weeks should be a
lot of fun hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time